[MUSIC PLAYING]
EVAN JONES: Hi, Evan here.
I'm a technical curriculum
developer for Google Cloud.
SANDRA SEQUEIRA: And I'm Sandra.
I work on our cloud sales team.
On this episode, we'll
introduce you to Cloud Datalab,
an interactive tool for
exploring, analyzing,
and visualizing large scale data
sets with just a few clicks.
EVAN JONES: We'll also take
you through a quick demo
of a self-paced lab where
we'll create a Datalab instance
as well as create and
manage a new notebook.
SANDRA SEQUEIRA:
Cloud Datalab aims
to help you get valuable
insights from raw data
while exploring,
publishing, and sharing
reports in a fast and
cost-effective way.
EVAN JONES: Datalab is targeted
largely at data scientists.
Creating Jupyter notebooks,
previously IPython,
has been a very popular
way for data scientists
to analyze data.
So it's no coincidence that
Datalab is based on Jupyter
and is also open source.
And what this
gives you is access
to a large set of open source
Python libraries for data
analysis, visualization, and
machine learning scenarios
that your fellow data
scientists have already written.
What it means for you is
that the notebooks written
by your peers can
easily be brought
into Datalab, which runs on
Google Cloud's infrastructure.
SANDRA SEQUEIRA:
As Evan mentioned,
the real power of Datalab
comes from its integration
with other Google Cloud
Platform services.
Datalab runs on
Google Compute Engine,
so you can choose a machine type
with the performance and cost
characteristics that suits
your data analysis needs.
In terms of
scalability, analyzing
terabytes or petabytes of
data is no problem at all,
because of the easy connections
to other Google Cloud big data
services.
EVAN JONES: All right,
it's time for the Quiklabs.
In this hands-on lab, which
takes about 30 minutes
to complete, we'll show you how
to create a Datalab instance
and create a new notebook.
SANDRA SEQUEIRA:
We'll also show you
how to use unget in your browser
and get from the command line
to manage your notebooks.
You can check out the link
to start the Quiklab here.
EVAN JONES: At this
point in the lab,
we've created a Cloud Datalab
instance called my-datalab.
We've used the web preview to
access the Datalab home page.
We then created a new
notebook, ran the code,
and saved the notebook.
Here, we're opening the
notebook's repository
using unget.
We give the commit a title
and commit the new notebook
to the Cloud Datalab VM repo
and push to the master branch.
To see the commit we made
using the command line,
we SSH into the
Datalab VM and open up
an interactive shell session
inside of the Cloud Datalab
container.
We can navigate the notebook's
directory in the container
and see the get log.
And this will include the commit
of our brand new notebook.
Well, that brings us to
the end of another episode,
and we hope you enjoyed it.
If you'd like to
learn more about Cloud
Datalab or other
GCP products, you
can check out our training
and resources below.
SANDRA SEQUEIRA: If you
haven't done so already,
check out this
link where you can
apply what you've learned
using a $300 free trial
credit on Google Cloud Platform.
EVAN JONES: Thanks
again for watching,
and we'll see you again soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]